welcome to this video playing a 15
minute game against higher Shikha
from India what am I doing here
let's play Sicilian trying to mix
openings and maybe we actually get an
open Sicilian yes we do testing this son
in the slide normally count the
Kalashnikov let's see there are two
principal line c-4 in 93 and after this
I'd like to get in a quick quick
it should be 75 but not quite sure what
the most precise move order is okay
let's see okay is playing the ship
should be three early
I don't necessarily need to play this
Bishop in 75 immediately I can also
prepare it and 9006 also that's that
either play Knight g4 maybe script could
lead to some coordination issues for
white the figure was denied once III now
for example there is a six ninety three
ninety four and on Bishop d2 there's
Queen b6 attacking f2 and B - it's not
not too great this does not look too
great for might maybe Bishop III wasn't
such a great move
he can play f3 yeah maybe you should
play f3 actually okay so now I thought a
six ninety three ninety four I mean he
cannot allow me to take the vision
really Bishop d2 Queen b6
yeah okay come on that's not let's not
pretend I'm doing anything else then
that just looks like the most logical
continuation maybe Bishop c1 really
Bishop c1 Bishop d2 Queen b6 is just
terrible b2 and okay he allows me to
take yeah maybe he needs to do it really
it's it's it's ugly but maybe there was
no alternative it's not so much let's
say the bishop payer I mean this bishop
on e7 but it's a potentially excellent
piece because his dark squares are so
weak or deformed for example yeah he
might okay he can take only seven if he
wants but this also leads to a
structurally very nice position yeah now
we'll try to keep it maybe Knight d4
coming our Bishop takes d5 well now I
can take on d5 and go to d4 that's also
not bad or I can go to d4 immediately
not clea what's better well let's let's
go there and decide afterwards I can
always take on d5 the point of the
CAPTCHA on the fibers that he needs to
check with the porn of course which
renders the d5 weakness or this weakness
weak spot completely irrelevant okay
I'll take it but it's a simple and
probably okay
yeah one issue is that I can never
really take only three as he takes with
the pawn and traps one night and that's
quite funny so but but this this should
be okay in any case get the rupiah and
decide afterwards where to had to put
the pieces or maybe he can play please
something like night that like a queen
before attacking b7 maybe yeah this
knight on d4 it looks very it looks like
a very strong piece but it is not so
clear what it is actually doing
while I'm certainly not worse um what
exactly how do i improve the position
Queen to b6 it's not really leading to
much maybe I can play Queen to d7 and
Queen to f4 try to provoke some kind of
weakness cm hmm it's not clear that this
is really something great
you can also just play b3 here yeah
maybe I'll play b5 just to Kevin C form
but it also beacons the pawn structure
and the light square so and it's not
like the perfect obvious means the the
the problem or assists that the knight
on d4 has no way to go after the capture
strategically speaking I wouldn't mind
to have an end game with the bishop on
d3 against the knight on d4 with the
Bishop g5 traded against the night but I
don't see how to to get to that the
bishop on d3 is always potentially bad
because of the e4 e5 pawn being on light
square so this is why a pure Bishop
begins tonight and game I would I would
like to play but it's hard to get to it
as it should be three years already
mentioned several times always answered
by F takes him and then the knight is
basically trapped on default can only go
to b5 which is totally useless you know
okay well opponent is not playing we can
do various things I would think about b3
I can maybe just take everything take a
c8 playbook c1 it's probably not not not
bad but maybe just b3 covering a for
covering C form nice taking quite a long
time him
there also moves like Queen to b4
also possible to get some player may be
against b7 just tying black to this pawn
yeah that starts to be a bit bit weird
but it's not disconnected no it's taking
three minutes three minutes for the
smooth castrating that's not bad
probably not really and but probably now
Luxio Luxio one wouldn't make oh no this
one mmm interesting the very night see
foyer okay well anyway I cannot I cannot
take only three four known reasons what
I want to have I want I want some some
looked for my King so that I don't need
to worry about a back rank made all the
time figure was Knight c4 I can play
that save Queen c7 look c7 something
like that and it's not a very dangerous
move
and while I don't really see what to do
I don't really see a great plan for
white as well
I wonder ever should play b5 maybe b5
next move
maybe b5 and getting then Bishop d8 b6
trying to use the bishop in the
direction of the King to on f2 or
something yeah that's an interesting
plan actually
okay well b5 it's not great mm-hmm I
wonder ever should really play this
Bishop td8 move can do that right away
hmm now that I think of it maybe g6 if I
intend to get to get it to be six maybe
g6 wasn't the most brilliant idea of
them now okay should be shouldn't be
terrible
f4 has an interesting plan for white
here we go
so what am i doing now this this okay
I'll start with that that's the right
one anyway I need to get rid of the the
noid but I'm not sure and if I really
should play Bishop e6 now I think taking
here is better right yeah that's
actually much better if he takes with
the rook I have the strongest Bishop g5
not
okay so then f4 was probably not really
a well-timed if he cannot recapture now
it looks very tricky forward maybe he
can but it does not look really great
Bishop g5 needs to go to f1 there is no
one no technical tactical trick coming
it looks a bit like that there could be
some some tactics because those pieces
are somewhat loose but it does not just
not really materialize
hmm I don't see any great follow-up it
looks very nice nice and active but what
exactly is my next move I would like to
get the Knight to e5 obviously but I
don't really see how this could be
possible I could also it would also be
nice to get the Bishop to e5 is there
some way to get the bishop there
maybe maybe this should be five he will
play rock everyone that's basically the
only sensible move and maybe okay
I wouldn't the exchange I'll do it
Bishop f1 I thought Queen e7
I bet the idea that Knight f3 is
answered by rook c1 trapping the Queen
and then Bishop f6 25 it's probably a
good plan white
yeah he just blundered into the into the
pin I thought I thought rook everyone
really and then my idea was Queenie 7 to
be able to answer this with Roxy 1
winning the Queen so the most obvious
move is not playable he needs to play I
don't know this may be something like
that and then my idea was to go here and
go to e5 this looks quite nice for black
ya computer gives me a pretty distinct
advantage have a pawn okay but it looks
really nice
the the bishop on e5 will be a very
strong piece and I maybe have some
taking chances even against the white
king the king is a bit a bit weak after
they have bonus move um yeah I'm not
sure at all about f4 I think this is
mostly a weakness you want to you want
to get some activity but it's it's
mostly weakening yourself here with
white I think if he if he is not doing
that but just stays it's very difficult
for me to to to make any a big progress
I have ideas I can do this let's say B 5
B should be six Bishop c5 and so
although Queen e7 Queen g5 so I can sort
of get things yeah how to how to tell it
yeah I can keep the game going and post
some some problems but
it's all should be a very comfortable
form for me but not a we know anything
when I wonder is after he allowed me to
get to this and if I have anything
substantially better
it really looks very bad to give up the
bishop but well maybe with whites very
nice control over the center it's still
not a terrible position yeah here I took
this is maybe debatable I'm not sure it
makes a position very static the capture
but you can think about other things I
mean typical sort of supporting move
maybe this even it's not not totally
crazy this is the idea yeah that's
certainly not bad for black but also not
nothing nothing fantastic yeah I think
I've always kept a bit of something but
he mostly am killed himself with this f4
and and rukia tunes this was a bit too
much okay thanks for watching